[Musique]
si vous avez moins de 30 ans alors cet
objet ne vous dira probablement rien la
cassette audio elle arrive en france
dans les années 60 et c'est une
révolution imaginez écoutez son artiste
préféré dans sa voiture c'était tout
nouveau à l'époque qui voulait atteindre
en voiture un programme stéréo et suffit
d'appuyer sur la cassette et c'est le
premier acte de la walck à partir des
années 70 la cassette audio se
démocratise plus pratique plus légère et
solide que le vinyle elle le supplante
peu à peu on la vend partout même dans
cette station service
quel genre de
[Musique]
demande particulièrement les groupes
anglais les derniers succès
en plus il est même possible
d'enregistrer ses propres compil
à partir de 1979 le succès de la
cassette audio s'amplifie encore plus
notamment grâce à l'arrivée d'un petit
bijou technologique
vous avez sûrement croisé au détour
d'une rue un de ses personnages bizarres
coiffé d'un drôle de casse rappelez vous
il ne manquait que les antennes pour
évoquer une autre planète mais n'ayez
pas peur ils ont simplement un groupe
man le walkman avec lui plus besoin de
rester chez soi pour écouter ses
cassettes le c'est une façon de se
couper du monde
c'est une façon se couper du monde je
crois et puis aussi
j'aime bien la musique j'écoute ce que
j'aime puisque j'ai cassé que
j'enregistre puis schieber à partir de
la fin des années 80 la casquette audio
est sur le déclin le cdh et la
remplacent petit à petit mais elle n'a
pas dit son dernier mot trente ans plus
tard elle connaît une seconde jeunesse
en france doit avoir autour de 2000
titres en permanence on en vend à peu
près une cinquantaine par mois
certains artistes sortent eux mêmes
leurs albums en cassette notamment en
raison de la qualité audio comme le
groupe indochine en 2017 je voulais
quand même montrer à nos téléspectateurs
que vous aviez tenu à sortir votre
nouvel album sur une bonne vieille
cassette avec un bon vieux walkman donc
j'imagine que votre ancrage est quand
même très dans les années qu'apple c'est
parce que le son est bien il faut il
faut maintenant des coudes sur le
téléphone est ce son est super bien pour
répondre à la demande une entreprise
normande a même décidé de reprendre la
production de cassettes c'est l'une des
deux usines dans le monde à le faire est
la seule en europe
[Musique]